I think it's important to have at least
one or two numbers that you track on a
weekly basis so that could be for
web-based properties or services or
products and having a metric that you
try to improve every week you can have
one or two of them you really shouldn't
have many more than that could be
conversion from sign up to let's say
first stage of sign up to completion of
sign up there are many different metrics
that you can use but you I think that to
keep the team focused especially in the
small company it's very important to
have one or two the folks on a weekly
basis I do failure differently than I
think many people I view it as a
feedback mechanism but if you look at
even let's say the 4-hour workweek
didn't start off called the 4-hour
workweek it was also turned down by
twenty six out of twenty seven
publishers and hopefully pretty soon
it'll be celebrating four years
unbroken on the New York Times
bestseller list and I like to whenever
possible illustrate those failures
because people will all everyone will
face failure or from mistakes and those
are the divergent points from which they
can either go in a good direction or a
bad direction and I want to illustrate
that oftentimes the finish line is only
a hundred feet from where you stand but
it might seem that it's a hundred miles
away
you just watch - amazing clips from Tim
Ferriss take the next three minutes to
sit quietly and think about how you can
apply them to your business and your
life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]